c'était l'une des grandes annonces de la
cérémonie de voeux de villepreux le
maire de la commune stéphane mirambeau a
évoqué la création d'un nouveau quartier
en entrée de ville le secteur s'étend du
gymnase alain mimoun au lycée
sonia-delaunay au total dix neuf mille
mètres carrés vont être aménagés c'est
un projet qui est important parce que
c'est une zone très emblématique c'est
une zone des centrales au niveau de la
ville et nous voulions réellement que ce
soit la vitrine de villepreux quand on
arrive on veut que les gens se dire
c'est ça villepreux et c'est là que j'ai
envie d'habiter
après un an de concertation avec les
habitants le projet prévoit notamment la
création de 250 logements et un grand
parc urbain avec un kiosque un jardin
partagé une aire de jeux pour les
enfants une grande pelouse
donc il y aura un grand parc urbain on
peut l'appeler même le central park de
villepreux et puis autour
il y aura quelques immeubles très
environnementaux très vert aussi et ça
va participer à l'attractivité de la
ville
ça va terminer la ville car ça va être
une zone qui va relier tous les
quartiers entre eux c'est un projet que
nous avions pensé en 2008 on est content
de l'avoir fait aujourd'hui avec tous
les villes croisiens des études de
faisabilité financière et
environnementale auront lieu cette année
si tous les voyants sont au vert
les travaux devraient débuter à
l'horizon 2020 pour une livraison
définitive prévue en 2025